what does this mean uh
for
a what you expect the the pandemic to do
and b how we will know if you know
what's the prediction of your hypothesis
yeah so what is what this means to me is
that we are currently
facing a very weird situation as i told
you already why where we have
a high level of infectivity of
infectiousness
but we have mild relatively mild disease
right
where
we know that this mild disease
is not due to neutralizing into
neutralization of the virus not due to
hurt immunity because on the contrary we
keep saying that
we we have high infection rates it's
very infectious so
what these vaccines are doing right now
is anything the generating herd immunity
yeah because herd immunity would mean
that you see a dramatic you know decline
of infection
seeing exactly the opposite so what we
are seeing is you know enhanced
infectiousness
but mild
mild symptoms
and if this is true what these people
suggest based on in vitro studies but i
must tell you brett these people have
done this in and you know it's just a
coincidence that i know the group
because i uh you know they uh one of
these people that i know very well got a
a grant from the bill and melinda gates
foundation and i was working at the
foundation so i know
and um
so they have been using cells
that are
really simulating completely the
epithelial cells in a sense that their
ac2 expression is very low whereas we
know at the upper respiratory tract ac2
expression is pretty high and they also
explain why
indeed in order to infect nevertheless
cells that have low expression in ac2
they need some kind of help it is you
know
normally
this transfection that takes place is
helping in fact because during this
when when the the virion gets
transfected you get
a rearrangement a structural
rearrangement of the spy protein which
makes it fusogenic and which enhances
despite the low concentration or the low
expression of ac2 you know the entry
into into the cell so i guess what i'm
saying is that now this non-neutralizing
antibodies or in fact preventing
preventing
you know this process from taking place
so in other words and we know i just
explained you they are binding
to these highly conserved antigenic
sites right so to the same extent as a
neutralizing antibodies we're binding to
the receptor binding domain and exerting
pressure
you know on
viral infectiousness because this
receptor binding domain is the part that
you know enables viral entry and hence
the infectiousness
the non-neutralizing antibodies by
binding to this you know antigenic site
within the n-terminal domain has been
shown that they might are know like
exerting pressure on another
characteristic of the virus which is
viral virulence right
and um
so there is no they don't prevent the
virus from replicating so
we still have high rates of transmission
higher than ever
so my
well guess is but of course i'm i'm i'm
only you know
sharing some fragments of the the puzzle
that i put together but is that again
the virus will be you know will be
capable of overcoming the pressure but
we know viruses can overcome pressure
that is exerted by by antibodies i mean
we have had the example we have we have
not learned from the first phase of the
pandemic because what what the first
phase of the pandemic learned this is
that
if we exert infectious pressure on a
characteristic of the sorry immune
pressure on a characteristic of the
virus without being capable of
preventing the transmission the viru you
know nature will do the natural
selection and will come will you know
give a competitive advantage to those
guys who are capable of overcoming this
right so and what is the result well we
have dominant propagation of a highly
infectious variant which is omicron
we have not learned that now you know
the
we are exerting pressure on the because
the virulence of omicron is lower is
lower than you know the virulence of
delta
so
we have not learned that if we are now
exerting pressure and we know how this
comes because there is pressure
you know of these non-neutralizing
antibodies by binding to this antigenic
site that is conserved the n-terminal
domain
you know we have not learned that this
immune pressure is also an immune
pressure just on another domain is now
highly likely you know of
giving a competitive advantage to those
guys that will be able to overcome this
and i'm describing this in my manuscript
that this is i think it's highly likely
that this will
will be possible by additional
glycosylation of the virus
i mean we can expand on this but it's
also very very
surprising to me that
if you read about glycosylated viruses
you know in every textbook of virology
will tell you that you know glycans are
so well suited to shield
antigenic domains from recognition from
antibodies and why is this well remember
this the the the viral membrane is in
fact part of the cellular membrane you
know with these viruses when the virus
is burning it gets enveloped by part of
the cellular membrane the cellular
membrane that is carrying cell glycogens
right so the virus is carrying cell
glycogens that are not recognized by
definition by the immune system but that
can shield you know in a whole antigenic
domain from recognition right
and um so
that is what i think uh is is very
likely uh to happen that the virus will
overcome this and that we will end with
a virus that is not only highly
infectious but also virulent and that is
completely resistant to all the
any of the of the coffee 19 vaccines
so let me understand this
i see
why
this model predicts
omicron is not the
uh natural vaccine that many of us hoped
it might be
right that effectively it's highly
infectious it's going to give everybody
natural immunity and we can finally be
done with this
your model is saying that's not likely
i'm saying it's the case
for the unvaccinated because it's just
going to train better and better you
know the immune system of the
unvaccinated people right
and that is a very interesting comment
because i need to say
brett that
right now when people are saying you
know what there is still a number of
unvaccinated people that despite omicron
land in hospital
every medical doctor every virologist
every vaccinologist knows that if there
is one thing you cannot do with a live
attenuated vaccine so omicron
is to immunize vulnerable people
or people who are not in good health
because there is always a likelihood
that in those people the virus will
break through the despite the fact that
it's attenuated
so the people that know land in a
hospital with omicron or people that you
would never ever vaccinate with a live
attenuated vaccine people with
underlying diseases with a weakened
innate immune system etc but for all the
others it's just you know
a training a training of the immune
system and you see the thousands the
vast majority of the population you know
unvaccinated
you know is is is not hospitalized right
right yeah
so okay i i read you loud and clear now
um
you're saying that that model which
many of us discussed i certainly argue
that this is a possibility
um
is
logically correct but only functional in
those who have not been
trained by the transfection
[Music]
uh uh
i'm trying to avoid the word vaccine
because i know it's not right but the
the the covet 19 vaccines right so now
we've got two populations one of which
is carrying uh effectively this
synonymizing
uh
port i described it as before i'm just
speaking
metaphorically and then the unvaccinated
population is still highly variable and
also is being trained by omicron
to be better and better at fighting off
closely related uh coronaviruses yeah
there is one important thing that i need
to tell you yeah that is that i told you
that non-neutralizing antibodies are
directed against an antigenic site
within the n-terminal domain that is
very conserved
now
so
people got vaccinated with the wuham
strain well we know what the s protein
you know corresponding to the wuhan
lineage
so
the receptor binding domain of of this
one so so
that means that people have been primed
their immune system has been primed to
recognize the receptor binding domain of
the wohan as well as the n-terminal
domain
right so now you come back with a virus
omicron
which has an n-terminal domain it's in
fact the antigenic site within the
n-terminal domain but i'm going to keep
it simple the n-terminal domain so to
say that it's very concerning conserves
are the same as wilhelm
yeah
the other is variable
so antigenic sin
tells you that when you have primed with
an antigen and you come back with the
same antigen yeah that those antibodies
will go through the roof
right so so the non-neutralizing
antibodies and you don't need an
additional omicron vaccine simply by the
circulation
and
people are highly susceptible to
vaccinies
they get their non-neutralizing
antibodies boosted like hell
for the none for the for for the part of
omicron that the part of the virus that
has changed it's the first priming
because in wuhan the receptor binding
domain was completely different
right so before new antibodies can
develop against a part of the virus that
has been changed dramatically changed
namely the receptor binding domain that
will take time before that can happen
the non-neutralizing antibodies in no
time will go through the roof enhance
the infection you see what i'm saying i
think if you take away
if you take away this resistance to the
non-neutralizing antibodies then the
enhanced infectiousness will
automatically result in enhanced disease
so if i understand you correctly what
you're saying is
you've got this n-terminal domain which
is highly conserved well it's a part
it's an it's a part the part that is
recognized by the non-neutralizing
antibodies is highly conserved and is
situated has been well described within
the in-terminal domain okay
so what that does is it is basically a
signal to the immune system that
activates
that fraction which was trained at the
same time
and so
trained on the wuhan s protein
the receptor binding domain which is now
changed so effectively
this is
tailor-made to trigger the immune system
to deploy an ineffective response which
now enhances the capacity of the virus
to infect is that what you're saying
yeah
it's just that we in that case we we
don't talk that much about the training
we we would rather say has induced
memory because it is about specific
neutralizing antibodies are still
specific and acquired antibodies but
that's a detail yeah i'm i'm speaking uh
colloquially yeah yeah
so that's uh that sounds like a recipe
for um
[Music]
a
a new phase of this pandemic
especially in light of the fact that it
predicts that there are two populations
those who have been transfected with
these so-called vaccines and those who
haven't who are going to have exactly
inverse
response to the future variants yeah and
uh so in any case one i would just say
that's
um frightening yeah it is it's also
proper scientific form it's a hypothesis
it's delivered with a prediction we can
know whether it's right you know and
as with your initial predictions it
might be that there's a nuance where the
model is mostly correct and then
something surprising
interfaces you know a lot of things
could happen but anyway we at least you
know
i think the thing is
very troubling to hear you say that
because i heard you say your predictions
before and although the world did not
unfold exactly as you predicted it was a
lot closer to what you predicted than
what anybody else predicted well it
occurs in two phases right this is and
if you think about this if you think
about this we got
variants that were more and more
infectious
at a certain point the virus become
became resistant to the neutralizing
antibodies
that enabled the virus that enabled the
virus to exert pressure on viral
virulence
because as long as you don't have
the non-neutralizing antibodies that
take over you cannot exert pressure on
virulence
so you have more and more infectious
virus then all of a sudden
you know the virus becomes resistant the
non-neutralizing antibodies take over
and those now start to exhort exert
immune pressure on viral virulence and
what i'm saying it is that
whereas at the beginning of the pandemic
the immune pressure
was gradually increasing because there
was like one variation or two or two or
three variations within the receptor
binding domain
now we are talking about
boosting of not neutralizing anybody so
all of a sudden in a large vast majority
of the population in highly vaccinated
countries we are having a huge immune
pressure right by these boosts right
and we have been
doing mass vaccinations so it's in
highly vaccinated countries the majority
of the population right because it's
always the population that exerts the
immune pressure when we we agreed on
that one single individual cannot do
this right
so
i guess what i'm saying is that whereas
you could think of the evolution of the
virus you know taking a more or less
linear course at the beginning of the
pandemic that what we are seeing right
now is like you know an exponential
thing and it's very very
strange that now for the first time
within one of these families
of ovarians the omicron even within this
family we have now
more infectious sub-variants to an
extent that the who has now decided that
you know the ba 4 or ba 5 we need to
consider them in their own right as a
variant of concern yeah that actually
begins to feel
like
um
an adaptive radiation
right and so i may be stretching a
little far here
but my sense
uh is that when we see an adaptive
radiation basically we see a branch of
the evolutionary tree that suddenly
sprouts a wide diversity but we haven't
seen this with delta we have not seen
this with government right exactly and
so my
my point is that actually there's
something selectively going on that's
different and what i would argue it's at
least consistent with your model that
what's happened is we've crossed a
threshold where the opportunity
basically the reward for experimenting
has gone up
and therefore the virus is now
experimenting in effect with different
ways of being so another explanation
could be that
the binding
of the non-neutralizing antibodies to
the antigenic site is still improving
[Music]
but you know i mean
that can still go on for some time but
you know the pressure is
i think enormous and that's why i'm
saying it's the value of fitness you you
know this from evolution right you have
the the selection but then the virus
need to be to become dominant right it
needs to cross this valley to become
more and fitter and fitter
and
yeah
so so the situation that we are in right
now
i think that is the summary at least of
my
analysis is completely unstable yeah
it's unstable the virus has not reached
the equilibrium right yes we have we
have not reached equilibrium and i think
one way of interpreting what you have
delivered so far
is that we have prevented ourselves from
reaching an equilibrium that we would
have gotten to and it might have been
very
painful we might have arrived there at
an unacceptable cost but we would have
arrived there and we're not arriving
there at all and we've got to ask
ourselves the question
how long are we going to keep
interfering before we realize we're
creating our own problem but you know
the problem is that we have now
a load
a highly infectious virus to circulate
and that that in its own right is
boosting people all the time yeah
we cannot you know we cannot
take this away right that is where i'm
saying if you're not because if you
think about this if you think about this
if the infection rate rises in the
population
then of course you are going to have the
prevalence the prevalence in the
population
of elevated
titers of non-neutralizing antibodies is
going to to increase
that is going to increase the immune
pressure on the whole thing
right the more immune pressure the
higher the infection rate so both are
interconnected so what can you do
mankind
can
diminish the infectious pressure
you know
massive
mass antiviral campaigns for example
right
but
if we don't do anything about this the
other thing is to diminish the immune
pressure now who is exerting this immune
pressure it's not the non-vaccinated
population is a vaccination
so if you want to achieve this
equilibrium and you don't
want to play
with the infection rate you don't want
to diminish this what you're going to
get
is that immune pressure need to diminish
to rupture this vicious circle
but that means that it's a population
that is exerting that immune pressure
you know that needs to be
reduced
in order to get your
60 70 percent of earth immunity because
now the earth immunity is like the
unvaccinated let's say 10 percent if you
want to increase this
right if you're gonna diminish
the contribution of the of the
vaccinated population then you can
increase this to like 60 or 70 percent
the other way to increase is increase it
but theoretical is a baby boom or it's
massive immigration from poorly
vaccinated countries or it is you know
the ultimate solution would be a vaccine
that prevents transmit that blocks the
transmission that induces sterilizing
immunity no we don't have this right now
frankly speaking i don't know about any
other solution right
dude
yeah that's very troubling so it's very
troubling yeah i mean i i that's why i i
told i told uh
you know dell victory do you really want
me to convey this kind of message
to your audience because you know it's
it's not good news but you know be happy
you know this as an evolutionary
biologist that this type of balance
between
a pathogen and an immune system has been
shaped over thousands of years through
evolution through like natural selection
all these type of things what we have
done here literally is we have
thrown a bombshell
on this thing you know on this delicate
balance that has been established for
many many many years right
and uh and then we we we would would we
expect that this thing is just going to
die out it's not going to have
consequences or micronutrients it's the
end of the pandemic phase as our friend
fauci is saying you know how can you
ever end the pandemic without cutting
dramatically the infection rate what you
are seeing right now is exactly the
opposite right
right and i don't know how we got here i
think it was a combination of
hubris
some kind of wishful thinking the belief
that we were entitled to come up with a
miraculous vaccine very quickly against
his stupidity arrogance and stupidity
and greed there's also an element of
this in which they don't feel the pain
because they're financially winning as
they deliver us these feeble products i
agree
[Music]